tägliche aktionen teil 2 was hast du
heute gemacht
es ist schon 14 uhr
ich muss mama anrufen es ist schon 14
uhr
ich muss mama anrufen ich rufe meine
mutter an
ich rufe meine mutter an
das telefongespräch
ich habe meine mutter angerufen ich habe
meine mutter angerufen
rufen
ich gieße die pflanzen ich gieße die
pflanzen
ich habe die pflanzen gegossen
ich habe die pflanzen gegossen gießen
der garten
[Musik]
ja ja ich habe verstanden du möchtest
gassi gehen ja ja ich habe verstanden du
möchtest gassi gehen
okay machen wir uns bereit zum gassi
gehen
ich schminke mich ich schminke mich
ich habe mich geschminkt ich habe
geschminkt sich schminken
ziehe mich an
ich habe mich angezogen
nicht angezogen
sich anziehen
die kleider
die schuhe
[Musik]
ich gehe mit meinem hund spazieren ich
gehe mit meinem hund spazieren
ich bin mit meinem hund spazieren
gegangen
spazierengehen
[Musik]
ich lese die zeitung ich lese die
zeitung
ich habe die zeitung gelesen ich habe
die zeitung gelesen
lesen
ich treffe einen freund zu einem café
ich habe einen freund zu einem kaffee
getroffen
sich treffen sich grüßen
das café
ich muss meine medikamente kaufen ich
muss meine medikamente kaufen
ich habe meine medikamente gekauft
ich habe meine medikamente gekauft die
apotheke
das medikament
m
ich sehe mir einen film an ich sehe mir
einen film an
ich habe mir einen film angesehen ich
habe mir einen film angesehen
sich einen film ansehen
das kino
ich stoppe
ich habe gestoppt
shoppen
ware bezahlt
mit der karte bezahlen
das einkaufszentrum
ich komme nach hause zurück ich komme
nach hause zurück
ich bin nach hause zurückgekommen ich
bin nach hause zurückgekommen
das haus
ich spiele mit meinem hund
ich habe mit meinem hund gespielt ich
habe mit meinem hund gespielt
spielen
ich füttere meinen hund ich füttere
meinen hund
ich habe meinen hund gefüttert ich habe
meinen hund gefüttert
für tare
die ki
[Musik]
ich überprüfe die nachrichten ich
überprüfe die nachrichten
ich habe die nachrichten überprüft ich
habe die nachrichten überprüft ich
überprüfe meine e-mail
ich überprüfe meine e-mail
ich habe meine e-mail überprüft ich habe
meine e-mail überprüft
die e mail überprüfen
die nachrichten überprüfen
jetzt lerne ich ein bisschen jetzt lerne
ich ein bisschen
ich muss noch die hausaufgaben machen
ich habe gelernt
lernen
nachdem studieren verdiene ich eine
pause nachdem studieren verdiene ich
eine pause
ich kann fernsehen
oder ich kann videospiele spielen
ich habe ferngesehen ich habe
ferngesehen
ich habe videospiele gespielt
fernsehen
videospiele spielen
der fernseher
die fernbedienung
jetzt möchte ich gern ein instrument
spielen
ich
[Musik]
ich spiele gitarre
ich habe gitarre gespielt
ich spiele die ich spiele geiger
ich habe geige gespielt
ich spiele schlagzeug ich spiele
schlagzeug
ich habe schlagzeug gespielt
spielen die gitarre das schlagzeug die
geige nachdem ich all diese dinge getan
habe habe ich hunger nach dem ich all
diese dinge getan habe habe ich hunger
ich bestelle das abendessen im internet
ich habe das abendessen im internet
bestellt ich habe das abendessen im
internet bestellt
bestellen
bumm
hallo liebe wir werden tanzen kommst du
auch
ja klar
auf dem weg schickt mir bitte die
adresse des lokals dankeschön
nachricht schicken
ich nehme die u bahn ich nehme die u
bahn
ich habe die u bahn genommen ich habe
die u bahn genommen mit der u bahn
fahren
[Musik]
ich tanze mit meiner besten freundin
ich habe mit meiner besten freundin
getanzt
getanzt tanzen
[Musik]
ich verbringe den abend mit meinen
freunden ich verbringe den abend mit
meinen freunden
ich bin müde
jetzt denke ich dass ich nach hause gehe
ich bin müde jetzt denke ich dass ich
nach hause gehe
tschüss leute bis morgen muss leute bis
morgen
bis morgen bis morgen
ich habe den abend mit meinen freunden
verbracht
zeit verbringen
die diskothek
ich werde mich jetzt abschminken ich
werde mich jetzt abschminken
ich habe mich abgeschminkt
ich bin bereit ins bett zu gehen
sich abschminken
ich fühle mich schläfrig ich fühle mich
schläfrig ich schlafe ein
ich schlafe ein
gute nacht
safin
und was hast du heute gemacht
was machst du in deiner freizeit
was machst du mit deinen freunden
schreibe es in die kommentare
[Musik]
daumen hoch wenn wir das video gefallen
hat und leid bitte das video